at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode of the tim ferriss
show is brought to you by the Tim
Ferriss book club I have a book club
where I resurrect or purchase books that
I feel didn't get the attention they
deserved and there's a brand new book
that I have put out called we learn
nothing by tim Crider and there are I
think five others including several of
my favorite books of all time so to get
free samples of all of them to check
them out go to audible.com forward slash
Tim's books that's audible.com forward
slash Tim's books thank you for
supporting the sponsors of this show
99designs
which is your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related go to
99designs com forward slash Tim to see
the projects that I've put up including
the mock-ups and drafts of the book
cover for the 4-hour body you can also
get a free $99 upgrade when you go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where I deconstruct and
analyze world-class performers
to find the things they have in common
most important the tools the tricks the
favorite books the routines that you can
use that they use and the figures that
we look at range from billionaire
investors like Peter Thiel to actors
like Arnold Schwarzenegger to musicians
like breda of glitch mob or Mike Shinoda
or Amanda Palmer to chess prodigies like
Josh Waitzkin and the point of this
podcast is to help you to question
assumptions to find a better way of
doing things whether that is agreeing or
disagreeing with these guests and it's
it's really an exercise and pushing your
comfort level and pushing you outside of
your comfort zone
and the guest for today is no exception
he's definitely going to help you get
excited one way or the other and his
name is Glenn Beck and there is no
secret agenda no secret political agenda
to this show that's not what this is
about and it is both not a gotcha
interview conversation with Glenn but it
is also not a softball interview with
Glenn so we we dig into a lot of his
personal habits and role models like
Walt Disney and Orson Welles for
instance but I also ask him questions
such as how he feels interacting with
Peter teal who's openly gay or how he
feels interacting as he has with Penn
Jillette who is a very open atheist and
I asked him a lot of questions that many
of you submitted via Facebook and some
of them are pretty hardcore and I think
he does a very fascinating job of
answering them so that is that now a bit
of background because I think Glenn is a
world-class storyteller he's also a
world world-class performer radio
personality and entrepreneur some of you
may not realize in 2014 for instance
Forbes named him to their annual
celebrity 100 Power List which pegged
his earnings at 90 million dollars for
that year and placed him ahead of people
like Mark Burnett Jimmy Fallon Leonardo
DiCaprio and Will Smith he is founder
and owner of the blaze calm which gets
somewhere between 30 and 50 million
unique visitors per month
which needless to say is massive and
there's no end to the the growth in
insights so it's a fascinating story
it's a controversial story but there's
something to be learned here and I think
you will enjoy the conversation so
withhold judgment reserve your judgment
and try to listen with an open mind
again this is not a political show I'm
not trying to convert you to anything
but it is a learning show and there are
some gems in here so without further ado
please meet Glenn Beck and for the
resources links show notes and so on for
this episode you can just go to 4-hour
workweek dot-com forward slash podcast
that's four hour work week com forward
slash podcast where you can also find
all the other episodes thank you for
listening
Glen welcome to the show thank you very
much I am thrilled to have you here we
were sitting outside at aquatic park in
San Francisco it was a gorgeous day
perfect and I was going to say has
anyone ever told you have the perfect
voice for radio but not today not today
I I know we have a block of time I want
to get into a lot of different subjects
the first question I really want to ask
is what your close friends or colleagues
believe you're a world-class at you know
I owe you always ask that question and
the punch in the face question and I am
I'm stumped by that because I don't I
don't consider myself world-class at
anything I think that I think that
I'm a guy who just kind of slips in
under the radar a bit and does things
just differently enough to where it's it
kind of short-circuits the system so
maybe I'm short-circuiting the system
baby okay this is this is an interesting
place to start so what are the elements
of short-circuiting the system that you
are gifted at or have developed a gift
for yeah I think it's I think it's just
it quite honestly let me to start here I
have a friend who is a economic
professor at Columbia and he came up to
me first time we met he came up to me
and it was a cocktail party and he said
so tell me mr. Beck where did you get
your education
nikka tommix I said I I don't have a
formal education of the self educated
man he said I knew it now I thought to
myself you sob yeah oh yeah here we go
and I said did you and he said yes
because I can't get my students to think
like you he said they're all they're all
trained to think a certain way so I
think short-circuiting the system is is
a lot easier when you're somebody Steve
Jobs is a great example that just has
not been trained to think like everyone
else because everyone else expects the
system to work this certain way and then
when you walk in and you don't have that
formal education you walk in and you
look at and you're like this doesn't
make any sense there's an easier way to
do this or a better way to do this and
you kind of chart your own path and and
everybody stands around telling you
don't do it that way and and you do and
it usually works job is a really
interesting example because he was able
to take disparate areas such as
calligraphy where he you know in that
case took a number of classes that he
then brought over to the development of
of Apple and its interface
let's let's talk about radio for a
second I think that actually before I
get to radio you did not graduate from
college but you took and correctly from
wrong one closet yes yeah what was that
class at Yale and I read that you were
encouraged or or or or introduced to
yell through a senator I just love to
hear a bit of the story surrounding that
I sobered up in my 30s I was alcoholic
and really a pretty despicable guy and
and very arrogant and just you know just
not a good guy and had tried remembered
not tried but I'd begun to follow the
path of my my mother who was an
alcoholic and drug addict and committed
suicide when I was 13 and and and so I
was gonna go down that road when I
turned 30 I knew my life was at a
crossroads it was either over or I was
gonna restart and at the time I thought
it was over but my daughter's convinced
me that I could start all over again and
so I did and I realized I didn't know
anything you know I was reading I was
reading everything I could get my hands
on and trying to educate myself because
I was just a self I was living in
self-imposed ignorance they didn't care
and so I started reading a lot and I was
reading Stephen not Stephen Hawking but
Carl Sagan's demon-haunted world and at
this time I'm not really religious at
all I was raised Catholic but I didn't
really believe in any evident and I'm
reading demon-haunted world and it was
all about technology but he was
comparing it to technology is going to
become like Latin to a lot of people and
there will be priests holders you know
and we're kind of there now it's like IT
can you fix this and you have no idea
how to fix anything and and so he was
warning about it but he was talking that
I don't remember what it was but he just
made some mention of the church
and I snapped the book closed and I
threw it down and it caught me off guard
and I thought what where did that come
from where did that anger come from here
I don't believe in the church and this
is something that was a thousand years
ago in the dark ages of course it was
like that mm-hmm and I realized I didn't
know anything and I thought how much of
what's in me has been planted in me just
through my experiences or just through
other people or my teachers or my
parents not stuff that I even believed
but just stuff that's been planted there
and so I decided to take everything out
and examine everything piece by piece
I was reading a letter from Peter Carr
about a month later for Thomas Jefferson
from Thomas Jefferson to Peter Carr
Peter was his nephew Peter was coming of
age and his mother had died when he was
young and his father was dying him
before his father died he went to Thomas
and he said you're the smartest man I
know
would you please oversee his education
Thomas said yes so as Peter comes to age
he writes this beautiful letter and it
starts out and says you know when it
comes to literature never read a book
out of its native tongue because you'll
lose too much learn the language then
read the book and he goes through all of
the the different studies mathematics
and physics and the last one is religion
and he says um when it comes to religion
above all things fix reason firmly in
her seat for if there be a God he must
surely rather honest questioning /
blindfolded fear when I read that that
freed my mind up to question everything
and so I began to and I started reading
Hawking and Einstein and Immanuel Kant
and I I mean I just couldn't keep up
with it myself I was just
prepared and um so I I decided to go to
school I was friends with Senator Joe
Lieberman at the time and so this was
around age 30 yeah okay and I'm talking
to Joe and said I just gotta go and he
said well why don't you go to Yale and I
said I'm I don't think I'm smart enough
to go to Yale and I said I don't
remember my I don't remember my high
school grades I think they were bad
because it turns out they were all A's
but I had such a poor image of myself
but I thought it was a horrible student
and so I was accepted and went in and
and I could only afford one class the
first day of class was the day my wife
and I decided to get a divorce
Oh and so it was really hard and but I
took early Christ's ology and I wanted
to take it out of the the theology
department I wanted to take you through
the history department and so I had a
professor named Wayne Meeks and he was
great and it was under classmen so I'm
this 30-year old freak in the class and
nobody knows what I'm doing there he
doesn't know what I'm doing there and
and I'm engaging him on everything and
the underclassmen love it because they
just want to skate you know to be in it
so I that I'm really keeping it busy and
at one point he said to me I was reading
I mean I really do have the library of a
serial killer I cuz I go and I look for
people who disagree with each other and
and so I was reading while I was reading
all the things that were supposed to
teach me about Christ I was also reading
all the people who were saying it's bunk
and I was reading a guy named Dominic
Crossan at the time he's a Catholic
theologian who doesn't believe in the
divinity of Jesus doesn't believe in the
resurrection or anything else and the
professor had said something and I said
well how do you explain then you know
this particular point of view and he
said mr. Beck who you reading
and I said I'm reading Dominic Crossan
he said don't read him he'll
hill-hill screw you up don't don't read
him I said okay who do you recommend I
read and he recommended somebody so the
next week I came in and I asked him the
same question and he said uh mr. back
didn't I tell you not to read Dominic
Crossan and I said yes he did you told
me to read this other guy and I've read
him and I get it but I want to know why
Dominic Crossan is wrong and he said
I'll see you after class turning point
in my life we went had lunch and he
looked at me and he said why the hell
are you here and I said because I know I
don't know anything I'm a [ __ ] and I'm
it's self-inflicted and I need to I need
to know what's going on in the world in
my life and what I really believe he
said what are you doing what are you
reading and I told him and he said who's
guiding you through all of that and I
said I'm not I'm having a hard time
getting through it and he said nobody
gets through that and he reached across
the table and I said well I know but I
I'm really struggling he reached across
the table and he grabs my hand and he
said you listen to me for a second would
you
you realize you belong here right you're
you're okay to be here that endorsement
and as stupid as that seems that
endorsement opened up my whole world
because it was the first time somebody
said you're smart enough you can do it
that changed my world I wish it hadn't
and in some ways I wish it didn't mean
so much to me but
I've learned from that now in my
position to say that to people because
there's something stupid in us that just
makes us feel like we're not good enough
we're not smart enough everybody else is
better if they just knew who we were if
they just knew how much I'm bluffing
you know I'd be caught no we're all
bluffing we're all trying to figure it
out
so that that brings me back to something
you said earlier that I'd love to
explore a little bit which is your your
daughter's convincing you to forge on
was that a conversation if so what did
they say to you can you tell me a bit
more about them because I think everyone
listening or a lot of people listening
have faced dark periods I know I've
faced some pretty dark periods and I'd
love to just hear a bit more detail on
that
I am I used to think I was a better
father when I was drunk because I
riddled with ATD and so I operated a
high-speed and I have a really hard time
sitting down on the floor and just
playing with the kids and like no no
don't you see the blocks we can build a
bridge and and so I would drink and and
I was a I didn't think I was an
alcoholic because alcoholics are poor
living on the street can't hold a job
and are abusive I was none of those
things and and I was a very
high-functioning alcoholic and became
even more creative when I was drunk and
so every night I would tell my kids a
story about inky blinky and stinky the
three little mice that would go to the
island of cheese where I would wear it
would rain parmesan and they were their
adventures against Thomas the cat and
they would go out on their marshmallow
boat every every night as they would
escape from their parents house and
I would tell them these stories and we
had a great time my alcoholism was
getting worse and worse and and I've
started to have blackouts and you know I
know that people in movies are like I
don't remember what I did last night
bullcrap if you don't remember what you
did last night you don't have that
attitude it's a scary thing and one day
my my kids came down to the breakfast
table and they were so cute and they
said dad tell us tell us last night the
story from inky blinky and stinky that
was the best story ever tell us again
and I realized I didn't even remember
tucking them in and I lied to them and I
said let's see how much you remember you
tell me the story of inky blinky and
stinky and I'll tell you if you have it
right and as they were telling me the
story all I could think of was what are
you doing what are you doing you you're
missing everything you're now lying to
your children about this what are you
doing and it had been about a two-year
struggle to finally get the guts to
admit that I was an alcoholic but that
was the weekend that I did it I left the
breakfast-table and looked for a place
for AAA and went into a meeting I know
we're bouncing around quite a bit
chronologically but how do you structure
your life to avoid the temptations or
problems that you've experienced in the
past and I think this is an AAA
expression but if you don't want to slip
don't go where it's slippery for
instance are there ways in which you
structure your life so that you I you're
insured against you visiting that past
yeah there's a couple of things I was
just talking to Jim Doty from the center
of compassion research of all tourism
it's damn stanford last night and he's
an atheist and he can he's totally cool
without any framework
he's totally cool my friend Penn
Jillette atheist totally cool one of the
most moral men I know really good decent
man I'd leave my children with him if
there was a problem I'd be like Penn
protect my children you know but doesn't
believe in God at all okay and honestly
as I told Jim last night my church the
one I go to it's a three-hour service on
the weekend good God Almighty that's
just agonizing three hours Dances with
Wolves it is it is you know and I got to
get up on Sunday and put a tie on and a
jacket I hate it I hate it but it holds
my feet where it needs to be and it
teaches me and forces me to serve and so
for me service is really really
important service meaning the weekend
service no difference has a service
meaning in my in my church
there's no paid clergy so everybody like
I'm a teacher my wife and I ran the New
York drug and alcohol addiction program
for a while for the church in New York
City and it's all non paid physicians
and so you're forced to serve and then
you're also we call it home teaching
where everybody is is responsible for
other families in the in the church so
your job is to go over and teach the
family and make sure the family is okay
and you know see if they need anything
because the bishop if you will doesn't
have the time he's got a job he's got a
full-time job so 300 families we ought
to take care of each other and so it
forces us to live the principles that
Jesus taught you know it's not up to the
government it's not up to your priest to
do it it's up to you to do it take care
of your brother take care of your sister
and you know that's that's probably the
biggest principle of a a that keeps
people sober is serve serve other people
how much of
the the service and the church being
able to hold you firmly to the ground do
you think is the the theology or the
scripture verses the the accountability
of having that social fabric ah I'm not
if that makes any sense yeah I think it
does let me answer and see if you make
sense to your question I really don't
care what other people think about me
and I say that somewhat hesitantly
because I'm not a robot you know you can
only take I'm actually grateful that I
get hit in the head as much as I do and
take the or I've handed the abuse that
sometimes is is reserved or deserved but
because it keeps me honest it keeps me
constantly reflecting am i that guy do I
believe those things am i a my head jerk
it and listen that but beyond that I
don't care if I'm rich or poor I don't
care if I'm famous or not and I don't
care what other people think I do care
deeply about what God thinks of me and
he's the only one that can judge my
heart and and that comes from being as
low as I was and you know for anybody
who doesn't believe in God or whatever
you they may not understand this but
when I I believe in the redemptive power
of baptism and whether it is a complete
sham it doesn't matter because it works
for me but when I got into the water you
know the promise is is that if you ask
for forgiveness and say I will obey you
and I will do what is right and what you
tell me to do then I'll remove all the
problems of the past I'll remove all
your mistakes and you don't have to
carry them anymore that was really
important to me because I was repeating
my mom's life and there was no out for
me
I mean I just couldn't live with myself
anymore and and I stood in the waters of
baptism and I don't recommend anybody
ever does this but I stood in the waters
of baptism and I uh I have a very
contentious relationship with God I mean
I challenged him and and I said you
promised your words promise that you
will set me free if I live the truth you
will set me free and if those truth if
that's not true and I live up to my side
of the bargain
then you cease to be God there is no God
because to be God you have to be
handcuffed to that truth you cannot
break your promise and I said the
dumbest thing I've ever said and that
was it's not going to be me that breaks
the promise dude and I challenged him
and that I guess was good for me in a
way because I think of that quite often
I challenged him and he kept up his side
of the bargain
and now it's my turn and so I do a lot
of things like when I left Fox
I left Fox because I felt led to leave
Fox I mean I it was really and I think I
would have I know I would have been
destroyed had I stayed why is that fame
is a really ugly ugly corrosive awful
thing especially that kind of Fame and
when I was when I was going up there and
we were you know being on the cover of
Time magazine and you know being as
ubiquitous as I was at the time is
really intoxicating really intoxicating
and right towards the end I remember the
last night that before I told Fox I was
leaving my wife and I had decided and we
had worked months
back and forth and that night I've
always been a pariah
I've always been I've always been the
you know kid that was beat up in school
and you know whatever I was never the
popular one and the night we decided I
was gonna go in and tell roger ailes the
next day I went to spider-man and I had
been to spider-man movie of the Broadway
show and I'd been in spider-man two
weeks before and they were that week
they were gonna close it but I gave it a
review that saved the the show and so
they invited me back and said hey we've
made some changes will you come back so
I came back that night halfway through
and get an email a text that says Bono's
backstage wants to meet you and say hi
so I go back backstage is Michael Cole
is Julie Taymor and and Bono and we
spent about 30 minutes talking about the
show and they were struggling with the
ending and I'm like you guys have the
ending the ending is the beginning
that's the ending you've got it in the
wrong place and as they were talking
about the ending I was I was walking in
to the meeting and I said they don't
know what the ending is and here's the
ending so when they said they don't know
at the ending is my wife looked at me
like dear god don't talk please don't
give them advice on this please and so
but I did and we had a great
conversation and it was like a cool mo
it was like I'm cool for 30 minutes they
go home and we lived in this apartment
in New York that was I mean it was movie
cool it was it was the Bloomberg
building on the 50th floor had a hundred
and eighty degree view of the city I
mean it was just spectacular
floor-to-ceiling windows and I walk in I
open up the door and all the lights are
off and there's just the city and I just
lit up and it's I'm looking right at
Rockefeller Center which is where I
wanted to work when I was a kid I wanted
to work in Rockefellers
it was a lifetime dream to be there and
I just had the cool kid night and I walk
into the living room and I'm standing
right there by the window and I said to
my wife how can this be God's plan we've
worked hard I know I didn't get me here
cuz ten years ago I was nobody so here
we are I finally have access I'm finally
starting to get in with creatives which
I'm better at then all this other crap
I'm doing and we can make a difference
in culture how can this possibly be
God's plan and I was lucky enough to be
married to a woman who does not care
about fame or fortune at all and she
just said to me I'm going to bed
and I stood there and I put my head up
against the glass and I looked down on
Lexington Avenue and I heard in my head
if you don't leave now you won't leave
with your soul and I knew that to be
true I was beginning to want it once you
want something get rid of it get rid of
it once you want meaning once you're
attached to something yeah once it once
you start needing something you know
once you're like I really want that then
you'll pay too high a price for it if
you're like this is cool you know my
kids ask me all the time dad why do you
always say enjoy it while it lasts and I
said because nothing's permanent I've
been rich I've been poor and you don't
know what's gonna happen tomorrow let's
just enjoy it for today and if we have
nothing tomorrow we'll enjoy that
tomorrow you know and I think that keeps
me healthy the minute you start to say
it's always gonna be like this or it's
only gonna get better or I can't lose
this you're you're starting to I am I
can't speak for everybody else I know
I'm starting down a road of trouble one
of the most fascinating aspects of doing
research for for chatting today was
discovering things like your friendship
with Penn Jillette
for instance which I never would have
anticipate
in a million years and well uh because
he would seem to be so antithetical to a
lot of your beliefs and I admire the
fact that you have that friendship
you've spent time with Peter Thiel for
instance who's openly gay how do you
feel about his homosexuality I'm totally
fine with it
how does it affect me it doesn't that's
why this oh yeah let me let me back up
with I think a lot of people there are
people who I think there are people who
project you know what they think
I believe no definitely yeah and which
I'd love to hear you tap one Penn
Jillette and I the only thing that Penn
Jillette and I really have found some
disagreement in is God and we respect
each other on that and at first we
didn't but I first met him at CNN I
spent an hour with him and I I just
think Penn Jillette is just brilliant
just brilliant adhere for years and
years and years and so we did an hour
with him and I finished and we're
standing on the set and had a great time
and I said Penn next time here in town
let's go have dinner and he said dude I
don't think so okay I said alright it he
said look Ben your religious freak
religious freaks your your cancer okay
you're the problem with the world and I
just stood there but I was shocked and I
said wow Penn I've thought a lot of
things about you but I never thought you
were a bigot and he said look I'm not
gonna bring a disease into my family I'm
just not gonna do it and that's what
religion is I didn't say anything I just
decided I'm still gonna be his friend
you know and I'd still invite him to a
show and and we'd still be on and I just
love him for who he was because I
respect him on so many other things and
years go by and Penn is really getting
conflicted because now I'm suddenly this
anti-homosexual but none of the things
that I
just I'm getting these labels sure
because you know I believe in X so I
must believe in Y Z and D and C and you
know am I'm not a Republican I'm a
libertarian and so I see this post that
Penn had done backstage and he's crying
and he said my childhood hero Tommy
smothers has just reamed me for going on
the Glenn Beck show I told him I was
gonna go on next week and he said how
could you possibly be with a bigot like
that in this bad man and I don't know if
I can be your friend Penn if if you're
gonna be friends with him and and Penn
was just torn up and I wrote to him and
I said Penn you don't have to be on the
show man I understand what it's like to
have heroes say things to you like that
and I really deeply understand
he came on he tried to corner me on
homosexuality out of the blue and he's
like so what do you think about gay
marriage and I said I'm totally cool
with gay marriage and and that he didn't
know what to do over time Penn came to
me just last year and he said I have to
apologize to you for something he said I
don't know if you remember but the first
time we met was at CNN and I said oh I
do remember and he said I hated myself
the minute I said it and he said I was
angry at 9/11 and I was confused and I
didn't know what I didn't know what to
do because of 9/11 and he said that's
not who I am and I said I know that and
I've known that the whole time and so we
become great great friends that's the
way we should be if we have the country
right now is
so screwed up because we're all talking
about interests instead of principles
mm-hmm why are why are we talking about
gay marriage why why do we even have the
government involved in marriage at all I
contend it's because of interests we
started issuing marriage license one of
the reasons why we started issuing
marriage license is so we could stop
blacks from marrying whites well that
sounds like a really bad idea why are we
still in that business right so all the
people are doing is they're using this
to separate us from each other I have no
problem you want to get married get
married
don't tell my church what I have to do I
won't tell your church or your judge or
whoever what you have to do let's just
leave each other alone let's just live
side-by-side and be decent to one
another let's celebrate real diversity
we're living in this world where we're
arguing about nonsense and real massive
the biggest issues possibly that man has
ever faced are happening right now and
we're arguing over what why how how
would you suggest people on opposite
sides of the fence try to find common
ground and the reason I ask that is when
I've observed a lot of whether it be
religious debates or political debates
oftentimes it seems like people are
unwilling to be moved
it's trans made they're afraid it turns
into a question of who is right not
being effective in terms of solving
problems how do you try to bridge that
gap how do you find common ground
with people who I tell you are massively
opposed to or feel like they're opposed
to you I will be friends I ever I the
the the Jefferson quote I gave you
guides my light guides my life entirely
because it has every important word in
it question with boldness even the very
existence of God so at that time when he
wrote that and for me there's nothing
bigger to question than God
okay there's nothing more damning than
saying I don't know if you even exist so
question with boldness don't be meek
question it the ultimate authority
question it question everything turn
over every stone and then because he
must surely rather honest questioning
over blindfolded fear we live in us in a
society where rarely do you hear honest
questions I haven't heard a dishonest
question from you yet I haven't heard an
agenda from you I haven't heard a gotcha
question you're not coming in and this
is what most people do they come in on
both left and right doesn't matter who's
doing the interview journalist generally
say I've made up my mind who this person
is and I'm now going to prove it
definitely that's not an honest question
so we're not gonna get anywhere so if I
sit down at a table with somebody who I
disagree and and they have and they're
really looking and they really will say
okay now wait a minute wait a minute
cheese holy cow maybe I'm waiter I maybe
I am wrong and they're willing to say it
I can I can I can meet with anybody
those people will change the course of
the world but that takes that takes real
confidence to say you know I think most
people are I was when I was at the
height of my alcoholism and I think most
the average person is like this
not sure there's enough inside of them
to be full and there is there's a lot
that's a lie and so if they get rid of
maybe their illness their disability
their complaints their childhood trauma
whatever it is I don't know if there's
anything left besides that that's who
I've become that's who I am
it's not that's not those are the bumps
along the way there's something there's
a gold nugget in each one of us you just
have to be willing to say I'm gonna get
rid of everything and I'm gonna go mine
for that you know the last the true last
unexplored frontier is inner space of
each of us we start exploring inside and
say I don't care what I find whatever I
find will be good whatever I find will
be real and authentic that's when we
really change things I've been very
impressed with how many how many books
you've read but of course there are more
books in the world than you could
possibly read consumed as one person
what are the books or book that you've
gifted most to other people probably a
book of virtues for anybody who gets has
a baby book of virtues by William
Bennett it's just all the old all the
old stories of of who we are and and how
we grow there's the things you tell your
kids the stories you should tell your
kids and we should relearn another one
that I think is really good is Jon
Huntsman's the senior Jon Huntsman's
book uh winners never cheat it's awesome
here's a guy who is really responsible
for the idea of the k-tel record and he
did
you know he he was trying to make a you
know he's the the pioneer of styrofoam
and he's trying to get enough money to
make the mold for the McDonald's clam
shells for the hamburgers okay and he
knows he can sell a million of those he
knows that's the perfect thing to keep
hamburgers warm when you go and you'll
just make these little styrofoam clam
shells but he didn't have the money to
make the mold okay and he had just he
invented the styrofoam egg carton and he
just knows but he didn't have the money
so he's like okay how can I make money
to be able to fund this other and he
comes up with the idea that you know
there's all these songs that I like but
I don't like the whole album I'll just
make a collection and I'll sell the
collection of these songs on one album
well those are look like the super hits
of the 70s that came from him he's a
petrochemical guy he doesn't he's not a
music guy a record guy he's a
petrochemical guy and so he really
thinks out of the box but more
importantly he knew who he was every
step of the way and in the book he talks
a little bit about making a deal I think
it was with shale and I don't remember
any of the numbers has been years since
I've read the book but he's he's doing a
deal with shale and it's it's a deal for
I think 250 million dollars and he's
selling off part of his petrochemical
company
well shells attorney starts screwing
around they have a handshake deal on it
he in the head of shale and the attorney
starts screwing around with it takes him
eight months well in those eight months
Jon's companies valued three times as
much and the head of shale calls him up
says John I need you to fly out and talk
to me about this deal he says ok so he
goes he flies out and he said he said
how can I help you he said well you know
we've been screwing around and so it's
our fault but you know I was hoping that
maybe we could we could kind of fall in
the middle here because I know we have a
deal at 250
but it's 750 maybe we could do 500 John
looked at him and said we shook hands at
250 it's 250 Wow
yeah and when you are that man that's
where your success comes from when you
can say money doesn't mean more than my
word
you know when we can get away from
people who are doing business and
they're taking you because they can you
know that's that's when we're in a
business world I don't want to be in
I've read that in the last two or three
years you've been trying to be positive
to be more positive I don't know if
that's that was in profile I read I
don't know if that's that's accurate but
if it is what was wrong and what are the
ways in which you've been trying to be
more positive or maybe it's a misquote
you can also no no I don't know if more
positive maybe less divisive okay no
let's talk about that as a lot of people
would accuse you being very divisive and
so I'd like to hear how your how your
thinking or behaviour change that was
never my intent and you know I never set
out to be I never set out to be the guy
I don't I don't want to be the guy on
Fox News I'm not Sean Hannity I'm not
Bill O'Reilly I don't like confrontation
how weird is that I don't like
confrontation
Bill O'Reilly loves it I hate it we'll
do it live yeah I mean I just hate it I
like it when we all get along I was the
I was the I was the the kid in the
alcoholic family that was trying to make
everybody get along how did I become the
divisive one it's not cool and so so
here I am finding myself in a position
that I've never wanted to be in I don't
like and I went to Fox only because I
believed the country was in trouble I
was saying the same things over at CNN I
was calling for the impeachment of Bush
on CNN because
what are we doing with the Patriot Act
what are we doing with the border what
do we what are we doing he's lying to
you what are we doing with the war and
nobody paid attention to me because I
was on CNN and it was popular to say
impeach bush I guess soon as I pointed
out the same things about President
Obama well then it becomes divisive and
I'm on a much bigger stage at Fox but I
only took that job and I knew I'd only
be there for a couple of years because
it's not who I am
not what I wanted I just really believed
that and this is why I always said in
almost every episode don't take my word
for it I don't want your trust I don't
trust people who say trust me I don't
I'm not looking for your trust do your
own homework and if I have it wrong I'll
lead with my mistake
and until I got out of there and now I
think I'm finally in the place to where
I finally have beginning to put the team
around me that is building the company
and the direction that is really truly
authentically me and that is let's build
a better world
let's let's look to people who are are
focused on principles and and ideas and
a brighter tomorrow because we choose
yesterday's gone tomorrow may never get
here but today we choose today we choose
I want to dig into I definitely want to
talk quite a bit about the company and
especially how you manage your time
because I'm just astonished with how
many ARMs to this business you have but
before we get there I'd be very curious
to hear a little bit about radio because
you started in radio 1913 and it was
until much much later that you got into
talk radio mm mm in that span of time
what was the best what were the most
important things you learned that made
you
that'll that helped you get good at
radio or what was the best advice that
you received
the best if I would just have to pick
one the best thing I learned I learned
by mistake I learned by self sabotage
actually mmm I I was
it was in the 90s I'm sobering up
everybody thinks I'm clean-cut
you know I had the image if anybody
listened in the 80s to radio in Los
Angeles I was kind of like a Rick Dees
kind of clean-cut mr. wholesome you know
golly gee mom you know that kind of guy
and and so
nobody knows I'm an alcoholic nobody
knows that my life is completely out of
control the people who work with me know
that I'm a complete ass but other than
that they don't and so I sober up and I
start going to school start learning
start really searching for truth and God
and those are all the things I can't
talk about and and I just don't want to
do radio anymore
because it's empty it's meaningless I'm
talking about Britney Spears and Madonna
and it's like what the hell is any of
this mean and and I got to the point
where you know I'm introducing the music
and stuff in the morning and I'm like
and that's that super classic from
what's-her-face and I was just go on and
I mean I didn't even I didn't care about
any of it and and at one point it's
during the Monica Lewinsky scandal and
it's a topic on the morning show they're
about eight people on the morning show
and somebody calls in and and said all
you know Glenn Beck you're mr. perfect
like like anything's ever you know
you've ever done anything wrong you just
know we can't accept a flaw on anybody
and I stood there for a while in the
room got really quiet and I said you
know let me tell you something you don't
have any idea who I even M or the bad
things that I have done let me tell you
who I am and the whole room just turned
like oh dear oh god what's about that
it's about to happen
and I spent about 15 minutes just being
unbelievably brutally honest and laying
out who I am
the worst not it not not no apology
nothing to say you think you know I've
been lying to you this is who I am I
turn off the mic and I looked at my then
in turn lowest producer on the ladder
who's now my executive producer Stu and
I said to him mark this down on your
calendar today's the day Glenn Beck
ended his career the exact opposite
thing happened I had grown up in a world
where everything was manufactured
everything was written timed produced
perfectly what I realized that day was
people are starving for something
authentic they'll accept you warts and
all if that's who you really are once
you start lying to them they're not
interested we're all alike
so the best advice I learned by mistake
and that is be willing to fail or
succeed on who you are it who you really
are
don't ever try to be anything else what
you are is good enough for whatever it
is you're doing Peter teal has a number
of very fascinating questions that that
he asks and I also you've spent time
with him I interviewed him on the
podcast he is a tough interview isn't he
yes he's a very incisive guy and he
asked questions including you know what
in I'm paraphrasing here but what
controversial thing do you believe that
few people agree with you on I want to
ask you it's a separate question but
let's start with that so what what
controversial thing do you believe that
few people agree with you on
that we have already seen our Archduke
Ferdinand moment Archduke Ferdinand was
the beginning of World War one and it
seemed like a disconnected stupid little
assassination that nobody was gonna pay
attention to and it had end up washing
the world in blood and I think that was
the I think that was the man who set
himself on fire in Tunisia I think that
was the thing that started the ball
rolling for the chaos that's now in the
Middle East and that Russia Putin is
either going to orchestrate or he is
going to be taken out by his own people
because he is allowed really very very
bad men who are uber fascists I mean
that literally
talked about Hitler in glowing terms but
Hitler didn't go far enough
Alexander Dugan is one of them he runs
the the Moscow University and really
frightening people and we are now set up
for a global conflict unlike anything we
have seen since World War two and I've
been warning about the Caliphate people
made fun of me on the caliphate and now
the Caliphate is in everybody's language
but when I talked about it four years
ago and said this is gonna lead to a
caliphate I was hammered and made into
the biggest joke in the world now I am
Telling You not only is the Caliphate
real the Caliphate this particular
strain of the Caliphate they actually
believe you don't have to but they do
they actually believe that they are the
army to bring on Armageddon and they are
calling on the armies they call it the
armies of Rome meanwhile Dugan and Putin
and his crew and in Russia
have just taken the Crimea and they're
doing it because they're becoming the
third the in Putin's own words we are
restoring the third Roman Empire and he
is trying to take back all of the land
that the Soviets lost and nobody's
paying attention to this and we we have
to take our troops out of there and we
have to pull back and stop getting into
everybody's business until we will at
least admit what the hell is going on
and be honest with ourselves we're
asking people now to kill people in our
name and I don't know why we're killing
them I don't know who we're killing I
don't see anything good coming out of
this and we're about to go into a global
conflict that people our age have never
witnessed what are you doing if anything
to prepare for that or mitigate against
how that might impact your life um I
don't know I mean I don't know how you
even prepare for that I really don't
right I mean I'm I've talked to you know
great financial advisors and I mean you
know when you're printing money all
around the world like we are and now
Europe is with QE there's this is not
gonna the the the the worst phrase
uttered today is well this time it's
different
no it's not it never is never is that's
a lie so you know I'm looking into
things like Bitcoin and you know what is
the new technology that's one of the
reasons why I'm here there there has to
be a
a group of people that say okay this old
system doesn't work it just doesn't work
the principles work but the power
structures the way they were made they
were I mean we're sitting here in front
of a building that was made you know by
FDR this is the this is we're still
using this power structure look at the
look at the architecture of this
building it's art deco it is clearly
from a different time we're using the
same structures for a world that is
totally different doesn't need any of
this crap so look for the people who are
thinking differently that can connect
and then more importantly are honest and
will and will honestly connect in love
and tolerance of one another when I went
to Auschwitz I took my family to
Auschwitz about three years ago because
I really I mean at the time I was
talking about the rise of neo-nazis in
in Europe which again mocked for look at
it now the Nazis are in Germany they're
in Spain they're in Italy and they're in
Greece the Golden Dawn party and I
talked about the rise of anti-semitism
in France and in Europe and look at it
now and so about three years ago maybe
four years ago I went over to Auschwitz
and I took my family and I had them read
that Corrie ten Boom story the hiding
place which she was one of the Righteous
among the men nations and she hid
families in her house her family did and
I asked my family let's decide who we
are now before trouble comes and let's
now build and water those seeds so god
forbid those times come we're prepared
and that's all it really has to you
can't prepare financially or anything
else you can prepare behavioral in
behavior you know and I talked to one of
the Righteous among the Nations his old
sweet lady she wouldn't let me take any
pictures of her but she let me record
our conversation and she was fantastic
and she said to me
I said Polina you were 16 at the time
when you decided to give a Jewish person
a bowl of soup
that was the first thing she did that
was a death sentence everybody has that
righteous seed in them how do we water
it she said to me and I thought this is
really important
she said mmm Glenn remember the
righteous didn't suddenly become
righteous they just refused to go over
the cliff with everybody else that's all
we have to do know what our principles
not our interests know what our
principles are today and as the world
goes over the cliff I'm not going to
change my principles treating human
beings whether they're like me are not
like me whether the same religion or a
different religion I will treat them
with love and respect the the the story
of the Good Samaritan most people don't
understand the Good Samaritan
if you don't hear that story of the Good
Samaritan and when Jesus says and you
know who was you know the good guy was
the Samaritan when you don't when you
don't hear an audience go oh that means
they don't understand the story let me
just tell that line over in today's
terms so you know the guy was that
helped the other guy on the side of the
road
it was jihad Johnny it's the most vile
person you can think of the most hated
person you can think of your biggest
enemy you can think of so the Samaritans
were reviled in that time they were the
jihad Johnny of the day so we have to
understand that even jihad Johnny we
better love we need to be loving to
jihad Johnny how do you demonstrate or
embrace love with people you fear to be
violent
I would say and I I don't I don't know I
mean I'm not it's a tough question I
have questions so but I I would say the
same way I love my children and I know
they're not violent per se but well yeah
let me just let me say my kid is violent
my kid goes out and he robs a bank I
love my kid but I turn him in because
it's the right thing for the kid and the
right thing for society but I go and I
visit him in prison and I love him but
uh I don't excuse it I and I I love him
every step of the way unconditional love
but not love that makes excuses
I would love to to shift gears a little
bit and I know a lot of people are very
curious about your departure from Fox
and the success that you've experienced
and just as my own personal interest
also I'm at a point where I have writing
the podcast started off as a lark and
now has it become quite a thing I'd say
I'm bursting at the seams and at one
point when you walked off a fox
I assume you're effectively starting
from from from an organization of one as
it were if you were and we're gonna get
into I mean some of the numbers just and
then we can we can update these if need
be but with GB TV so your streaming
network if you're featuring your daily
TV show in its first year generated more
than 40 million dollars in revenue
compared to the 2.5 that you made at Fox
News if you were doing it all over again
or giving someone advice who is doing
the same thing what are the first three
hires that you would suggest they make
I was a civic Li in the content game
sort of in in the world that you operate
in the media content let me answer that
a little differently whether the answer
in a way that I think you need to hire
which is at Facebook yesterday and
everybody there is a fan of Mark
Zuckerberg Mike Mark Zuckerberg okay you
don't really find anybody's like yeah
you know mark is okay it's important
that the team you have around you are
not yes people but they are one with you
if you're the visionary they have to be
one with you they should throw you up
against the wall go clan that out no I
don't thinks I don't know how that works
I don't understand it show me the vision
you know I mean help me explain explain
this to me again but they have to be in
the pocket of exactly what you're trying
to do and and that was that I got a
little too broad with with some of the
hires you know we had to hire and and
and take on she's I think we went from
30 30 or 60 people to 300 overnight it
was really hard
you just can't hire that fast and and
higher right and we hired a lot of
people that were not in the pocket and
so they didn't see the vision and it's
it's as I explained to my staff here
recently I just went to a store in I
went to the new Ralph Lorenz store on
Fifth Avenue in Manhattan and either
take all the labels off of it and I
could walk by the windows and I'd know
it's Ralph Lauren I walk into the
entryway it's all wood paneled and it
just looks like Ralph Lauren you go in
and and now of a sudden it's it's it's
Indian moti
and and hunting lodge Ralph Lauren a
screams it upstairs it's all white walls
black polished floors and black and
white photos and all of it screams Ralph
Lauren and I thought to myself how the
hell does Ralph Lauren do this how does
he do this it's because most people I
think can see the difference can see
Ralph Lauren and Tommy Hilfiger most
people will see those two ago and as
pretty close Ralph Lauren Brooks
Brothers one's got a pony one's got a
matter lamb or sheep whatever gets on it
okay so I got it but the same thing
they're both button-down shirts not to
Ralph Lauren they're not they're wildly
different and if you don't hire the
people that know the difference between
Brooks Brothers and Ralph Lauren if you
don't know the difference between Tommy
Hilfiger an American East Coast kind of
guy and Ralph Lauren it's not close
enough and so he developed the team that
could see the vision and then execute
the vision and didn't have to come back
to him every time that's really hard to
do really hard to do but you've got to
have a head of product first and they
open they over see the the unity of the
messaging on these to make sure that
vision is consistent every step of the
way the second thing is and we did this
poorly really poorly and I'm I'm
spending all this year doing working
with a new head of product that we
haven't hired yet and somebody else I
haven't hired yet new head of customer
service there is nothing more important
than my tribe and you know we most
companies and let me just speak from let
me speak from me and I'll just give you
the warts of my company I started
looking at my company over the last year
and I had been really sick and and
thought when I left Fox I was sick and
most people didn't know it and
uh I thought my wife and I had talked
about it that this last Christmas would
might be my goodbye and I would leave
the public sphere
this last 2014 yeah and and we had given
it my health to recover 2014 and if it
didn't recover then it would then we
would leave and I would just go off into
the sunset and and so I had some miracle
doctors and some miracle cures happened
over the last spring and summer and and
and in this last six months and so I got
enough brain power back if you will to
be able to really look at my company
because I had turned my keys over to my
my partners and said hey take this and
what we had done is we had flipped the
entire company upside down and we had
become a company that was about profit
make the money make the money make the
money and then protect that profit don't
let anything happen to that profit you
got to keep keep that money in there and
then what products can we make to make
the money make the money make the money
then people well that that's upside down
and principle learning in the team that
you've hired the team and the tribe okay
the company and I think all companies to
be successful need to be the exact
opposite so I went back in over the
summer and I said we're flipping this
whole thing upside down the first thing
is principles why do you get why do you
come here why is anybody getting up in
the morning we do it because we believe
in something right what are our
principles what drives us what do we
know that we could say oh we do this
because of these principles okay we're
never gonna violate those things then
the next thing is the people our
principles revolve around the people our
tribe and the people that we work with
then because we love the people and we
know our principles then we're gonna
find the product that makes life easier
for the people that we love and serve
then we're gonna protect those people
and those products
and those principles at all cost and
profit becomes a byproduct that's that's
the way a company needs to work what's
an analogous has supposed to what's on
the Facebook walls when you walk into a
lot of the buildings which is a quote
from Zuckerberg saying we don't make
services to make money we make money to
make better services right now at the
same time who's who's the first person
I'm I'm stunned by how quickly you were
able to hire and your team was able to
then expand coming out of Fox News had
you had experience hiring people before
and who was the first person that you
hired to Betsy Morgan all right I've
last and she was the she was the head of
HuffPo see a CEO of HuffPo and quite
controversial yeah because everybody's
like what what what are you doing but
she was the fastest hire I've ever made
how did you how did that hire happen
through friends mutual friends and Chris
Balfe who was running my company at the
time he had done a search and talked to
her and said you should meet with her
and I said alright and met with her and
literally I'm really fast hire if it
drags on it's not gonna happen but I was
sitting with her for about three minutes
and I was done because I could tell she
had good quality principle she was
honest and full of integrity and you
know obviously she's smart about getting
into the office unless you're smart but
she has been she's been fantastic now
she's the the CEO of the place she's
replaced Chris what did she say or do in
those three minutes that made such an
impression to you I'm a I'm a gut guy so
I can't remember anything that we even
talked about I just looked her in the
eye and I just felt she was a person of
real principle and I asked her do you
know who our tribe is she said yeah I
said tell me about it
what'd she say I don't I don't I don't
recall I think it was probably somewhere
along the lines of you have a wildly
underestimated underserved and
misunderstood group of people and that's
where that's true we have this massive
audience that nobody's serving anymore
at 27 million plus uniques a month to
the website something website I think
the total the last total I saw was like
50 million footprint at 50 million a
month which is insane
it's hard for me to go back in time and
and and and redo what I've done but if I
could start all over again today the the
first thing I just hired a guy named
Jonathan Schreiber and I look at him as
an architect you know he he can build
the structure I'm I'm an I'm not a
business guy you know I'm more of a
creative and content and I can see that
I can see the vision of where I want the
company go but I have no idea how to
build it per se so I need an architect I
need somebody who can really see my
vision really get it and then say here's
how the structure works because for
instance I know I want a I want an
extraordinarily flat operation and you
know that's one of the things that we
you know we built in properly we were
building a lot of stuff up in New York
and it was being built like CBS and it's
not a flat organization and that doesn't
work and it's just not gonna happen I
want a very mobile empowered group of
people to work with me that doesn't have
to go through a lot of red tape so you
need a good architect and then you need
somebody who's looking at the the
product itself and the customer protect
the customer protect the the content or
the product
and protect the flatness of the
organization I've heard that question
you sometimes ask is how is your soul
and you have very very good eye contact
what do you look for or get when you ask
someone that question do they even know
what that question means have they have
they are they just skating through life
you know do they answer that question
like oh yeah my soul is good or have
they pondered especially and I ask that
I ask that generally of politicians new
politicians because most of them don't
have any idea what they're walking into
that is I mean there's no hope in
Washington by I mean on either side I
don't I don't know how you do it you're
walking into I mean the Lions Den would
be a picnic it's just it's a cauldron of
rot and and everything and I know this
because of the media had I wanted to
play the game I could have made a lot
more money for the rest of my life and
be given anything I've ever wanted okay
they'll give you anything as long as you
perform give it to him the same thing
with with politicians you're going in
there play the game brother play the
game just make it all go you're gonna
you and your family gonna be taken care
of forever don't worry about anything
and so your soul is gone before you know
it you first think well you know what if
if I just compromise a little bit I'll
be able to do X Y & Z you're done you're
done so how's your soul right and if
they take it lightly they're not they're
not the guys yeah if they are afraid of
losing their soul then they have a
chance I don't let somebody who's like
cheese man I got to get out of there
before I lose my soul because nothing's
worth losing my soul so they at least
demonstrate that self-awareness yeah and
the nd and
the the awareness that there's more to
life than being successful or or being a
senator or you know I don't believe in
Saul Alinsky that you can that the ends
justify the means they don't believe in
that we don't torture I'm sorry one of
the reasons why we're having a problem
in their countries because we torture we
don't torture and so we've diminished
who we are the ends don't justify the
means
what does your the first sixty minutes
of your day look like ugly ugly I get
your morning routines or habit uh get up
in the morning around 5:00 read for
about fifteen minutes just check the
news check Facebook what what news new
check just generally the blaze and just
the quick headlines
I'll check the blaze Drudge Business
Insider Zero Hedge I like Zero Hedge a
lot and then just get ready I start I
get up in the morning I say my prayers
for probably five minutes then read then
get ready then get in the car
try to watch you know any clips that
might be wanted for the radio show or
for television then I go in and I have
my first briefing within that first hour
what are your prayers are there the same
prayers each morning
no they're just I mean generally they
are help me help me see the things that
I'm supposed to see help me avoid doing
damage help me be wiser than I was
yesterday
and do you do that at the kitchen table
do you do that in your bedroom where
it's where's that other side of my bed
that's beside your bed yeah
and when you go into the office for your
first briefing what how is that briefing
organized what happens in what happens
in that meeting I have the main
executive producer Tiffany Siegel she
produces television she gives me a
briefing I get three briefings get one
from Benjamin Weingarten he is a guy who
looks at things that are a little deeper
than the average person maybe he's
looking into the Middle East he's
looking into Russia for me he's looking
a little more over the horizon for the
deeper issues and he'll give me probably
15 stories a day then I have another guy
who is actually from Silicon Valley
who's kind of a a mole for me that is is
is fascinated by the singularity as I am
and Ray Kurzweil and he looks at
emerging technology on a on a much
bigger scale I'm not interested in the
latest app I'm interested in the
singularity and the ethics that go
behind that and so what's coming and I
get about 10 to 15 stories from him a
day then Tiffany Siegel she gives me the
about 10 or 15 stories that are
considered useful for television on
things that she knows I'm watching for
that how are these stories given to you
what's the format I get a one sheet with
just a quick brief on it and then I get
the full story so I get packets got it
so each one basically has a it's almost
like a research paper you have your
abstract on the front page yes yes
attention that line and then the end
then I have the full story and then I
get one more briefing from the radio
division and those are all the stories
that they're looking at for radio and so
I in that in that second hour it
you will soon as I get to work in that
second hour I go through all of those
briefings and decide and pick the
direction of the the day and then
longer-term how do you choose the how do
you choose those stories for the day how
do you choose the right combination of
stories I have absolutely no idea just
my gut just whatever is whatever is uh
whatever interests me you know whatever
I think I'm the one thing that I am
decent at is tying stories together
I can see connections on stories and see
things that how they can come together
that most people don't and I think
that's the one of the problems with the
news and and with today is everything's
just a separate topic it's not really
it's not we're all connected and the
stories are all connected what's
happening in the Middle East does matter
here and you know what's what's
happening on Facebook matters - to
people what type of tools or software do
you use our apps on a daily basis help
you manage your time because I think the
thing most people listening to us
probably don't have an idea of the
breadth of of your business in so much
as you have all the content you have
clothing line you have a very large
business what are the tools tricks they
don't help I don't I just have a really
unbelievable staff I mean it is really I
went through a period where my day is so
scheduled that they we call it the great
sock incident of oh-6 because I just
snapped one day because I had gone from
a regular life to you don't have a life
blend everybody has to do everything
else for you you have to focus on what
you do everything else in life you don't
know you no longer get to do okay and
and I wanted to go buy a pair of socks
that's all I want to do five hair songs
and areas like Glenwood get you
so I'm like no I I want to go buy a pair
saw I want to go buy a pair of socks and
it went on for like two weeks okay we'll
schedule it at time for socks and
finally I just like I just flipped and I
was like I'm going right now and I'm
gonna buy myself and I'm buying a
fricking pair of socks that was the last
time I wigged like that but you just
have to kind of get used to your time is
is no longer really your time you you
have to I read a great book years ago
there's two of them and I don't remember
which one this was in but in the mind of
a millionaire or a millionaire's mind
and Millionaire Next Door something that
one of them was talking about how unless
you're a plumber don't fix your own
plumbing okay because you're gonna spend
way too much time on that and and you
can hire somebody my eye I concentrate
on the things that I do best and let
everybody else do everything else so I
have very regimented times too where you
know I just had somebody shadowing me a
couple of days ago and I think they
freaked out they were just I think they
were about to go into an institution
afterwards because they they had no idea
what it was and you know I was in I come
right off of radio that day and I walked
right into another stage where we're
doing claymation and I'm talking about
the claymation and we're talking about
the story and so I'm looking at the
claymation I'm looking at the shots then
I'm talking to them about the story I go
upstairs and I'm talking to them about
the orchestration and the and the all of
the music for the story and kind of
doing a quick download on what it needs
to sound like and they're showing me you
know some pieces of music that have been
coming back and then I go right from
there I go to the clothing line where
we're looking at sweaters and designs
and what I want for the designs to be
you know in the patterns of the sweaters
I'm talking to them about what are the
companies that are making
nice for us what are the conditions for
the workers etc etc hmm and then I walk
out of there and I'm into another TV
shoot that we're doing for a special for
three weeks down the road and I get my
briefings as I'm walking from place to
place and so it's enough to drive you
insane until you get used to it you know
did you change anything after the socket
incident of O six or I let it go you'd
let it go I just let it you just become
accustomed I just let it go and and then
there are times to that we just schedule
in I just I just want time I just want
my own time now you know so you block
that out in the calendar yeah when you
hear the word successful who's the first
person who comes to mind
you
gosh the first person that came to mind
was Billy Graham only because I I was
talking about him last night and when I
met with him he was the most at peace
man I've ever met in my life he was just
totally comfortable and and happy and he
said to me with tears in his eyes he
said I'm not afraid of death and he was
smiling I'm not afraid of death the
whole dying part has me a little freaked
out but death I'm not afraid of and he
said I've done my best every step of the
way I've tried I failed on many things
but I tried my hardest every step of the
way that's success to me can you get to
the end and go man I screwed it up but I
tried you have mentioned before we had
we had dinner a few nights ago with with
group of folks here in Silicon Valley
Walt Disney specifically also George
Orwell quite a lot why the fascination
of these two men George well not so much
maybe Orson Welles I'm sorry yeah yeah
yeah that's right we're nothing cup of
coffee
yeah because Orson Welles let me start
with Orson Welles he played a role in
the early part of my life at 8 years old
my mother gives me a set of record
albums called the golden years of radio
and uh and it's because I grew up in
Seattle and it was a day like today it
was beautiful outside and I was in
watching TV and I must have been seven I
think and and she said turn off the TV
go outside and play and I said you watch
TV when you were a kid and let's talk
back to her and then she sent me down
and and taught me not to talk back to
her and then said you know we didn't
have TV when I was a kid and I mean I
just was thinking Wilma Flintstone had
TV how old are you and uh and she got
for my eighth birthday she got
this record album of group of them and
most of them were Orson Welles War of
the Worlds the shadow there was Jack
Armstrong the all-american boy fibber
McGee his closet all these great classic
radio shows so eight I knew exactly what
I wanted to do I wanted to tell stories
and I thought radio and the spoken word
was so much more powerful than anything
Hollywood could do anything television
could do because your imagination is so
much stronger and then growing up and
learning about Orson Welles he taught me
that two most important things one never
give up and two because of his failure
and borderline insanity I think on on
never admitting defeat let it go let it
go is this Citizen Kane specifically
yeah let go now I what was he not able
to let go of and why was it important
that he let go because he took on I mean
Citizen Kane is his masterpiece he took
on a fight that he knew any bit you know
anybody who was less arrogant would know
you're probably not gonna win which
fight was this and I don't actually know
you know my history he was he was
Citizen Kane is the story of William
Randolph Hearst right and it's deeply
personal rosebud is the name that
William Randolph Hearst gave to his
mistress private parts okay so I mean
it's it's very direct in your face okay
the most powerful man on the planet
where you gonna take him on you're not
coming out without a bloody nose maybe a
broken head all right
so he gets his head kicked in on that so
what happened I actually don't know okay
so he makes this movie he's bluffing
right at the time he is uh he's the
highest-paid guy in Hollywood
more than
spencer tracy more than clark gable he's
never done a movie okay he's done
macbeth with an all-black cast in new
york he's done all of the best radio
shows he's he's brilliant and he's got
all of this stuff going but he's never
done movies so he goes and he he does he
goes out to RKO they pay him a fortune
he's bluffing he doesn't have a story he
goes up to San Simeon and he sees a
small Hearst Castle and he's like this
is story we're gonna tell that's insane
it's a closed set nobody knows what's
going on he writes it all header hophead
a Harper who's the gossip columnist at
the time she finds out about it once
it's all done she tells Hearst Hearst
goes the earth´s that giving you a very
short story version of this Hearst
eventually goes to all of the heads of
the movies the studios and says here are
the pictures of the homosexuals that
work for you here are the pictures and I
don't think I need to remind America
about all the Jews that work here and he
just takes them all out and says I'm
gonna destroy all of you I want this
film destroyed Wells gets on a plane
flies up to RKO in New York and meets
with all the Jewish investors and the
board and it's right after
Czechoslovakia and so they're very well
aware of what's happening at Hitler well
wells gives one of his best performances
ever and basically he says you don't let
one man squash the free-speech of
everyone else they release it Hearst
destroys him in it it's just yeah just
just hammers it
it's remembered as a horrible movie and
everything else not found until the 60s
once found in the sixties already
realizes this is some masterpiece but he
couldn't let it go he couldn't let it go
he didn't give up the fight no just just
let it go man you did a great thing
now go do something else how well have
you found that to apply it to your own
life have there been any moments Werner
that has been particularly relevant for
you
yeah I think right now is one of those
moments for me on I believe the things
that I believe about the country and the
direction that we're headed with
progressivism and I don't agree with it
but the country's made its choice okay
let it go and now let's see what impact
I can make in a positive to help bring
people together and make it the best
that we possibly can so we don't go down
some of these horrible roads that we've
gone down before in the past
what about Walt Disney um Walt Disney
most people don't know Walt Disney was
responsible for the death of his parents
I didn't know yeah that Walt I loved
because he was eternally optimistic and
he believed in a better tomorrow and he
had a horrible childhood his father was
abusive and his mother he loved but his
father was he just was not a good guy
and was it was a loser and but Walt and
his brother loved him and and wanted to
bring him out to California so when they
first became successful they decided to
buy a house but they didn't you know
back then you didn't have inspections
and everything else so they bring the
family out his father calls him right
soon as they move into the house his
father calls him says wall something's
wrong with your mom you've got to come
to the house quick she's sick
something's wrong when they got there
they were both dead on the floor there
was a gas leak so the house that they
bought their family and then didn't do
the dude' inspection of right had a gas
leak and it killed their parents they
never ever spoke about it so he had
really tragic stuff happening his life
but he was really really optimistic more
importantly Walt I think saw the future
um I have a book that um was really hard
to find it was the book that he carried
in his pocket the last ten years of his
life it's called the garden cities of
tomorrow is printed in 9th in 1898 and
it's the first book on urban planning
this is the key behind F Codd and what
he believed
Epcot was Epcot is a dream killer I was
just talking to the head of Imagineering
at Disney and we were talking about he
was there part of the team as a younger
man making Epcot and he said I said out
of that feel and he said I never felt
like I had ever killed a man's dream
more than making Epcot and Walt saw the
future and was responsible in many ways
for us going to the moon he was the guy
who brought Wernher von Braun and Ward
Kimball together and did a episode in
1955 called man in space because of that
episode the legend is that Eisenhower
called Walton said Walt you son of a
[ __ ] he did it
I've been trying to convince the
Pentagon we could go to space you did it
better you convince the American people
and I think in 1955 it was very much the
same kind of atmosphere that we have now
to where people are concerned they don't
know the technology is all about to
change we could destroy ourselves in a
heartbeat we you know they had the Cold
War we now have what's brewing over in
the Middle East we're afraid the world
is changing under our feet rapidly
somebody just needs to be a warm blanket
and say it's okay look this way look to
Silicon Valley look to space look to
what's on the horizon if we all just
take a deep breath relax believe in the
best of one another believe that this
the principles of America work we're
gonna make it and it'll be a far greater
tomorrow than it has been in the past
that's part of the reason of all the
places in the world I've chosen to live
here
in SF and Silicon Valley's because
there's such an element of optimism and
possibility with Peter people like Peter
Diamandis actually lives in LA but he's
chairman of the XPrize and you know the
Elon Musk's of the world ironically
enough also in SoCal but it's it's a
place where if you will ask why not yes
quite a bit I'd love to ask one more
question and then a few questions from
my for my listeners first is if you
could give your 30 year old self
one piece of advice or two pieces of
advice what would it be relax why I
don't know i-i've always been in a hurry
and I've always felt like gotta get it
done gotta get it done
relax let it let it let it happen
it's nothing ever is good when it's
forced nothing's ever good when you try
too hard you know do your best then let
it go if you could give yourself one
more piece of advice when when you've
just got hired to work with Fox News
what would that advice be I know and
I've thought about a lot and I'm trying
to think of an answer here I I was
really believe it or not I tried really
hard to do the right thing I don't know
what advice I would give myself because
I know I didn't do it right I don't know
how else to have done it in that time
period of where I was you know what I
mean
maybe this is I mean it sounds horrible
but maybe they won't listen they won't
listen but I don't like that advice
because that leads me to say it's passed
on try yeah
stuff I've heard said before uh you know
the person who says nothing can be done
and the person who says everything will
be alright are the same because neither
does anything yeah and that's that and I
don't I don't accept that and but I
don't know how else to have done it I I
mean I I have racked my brain on it and
and I racked my brain then I mean you
know you have to be a pretty bad monster
to kick up the dust that I kicked up
without any reflection on it during it
you know what I mean you I mean I think
that would probably be the more
surprising thing uh you know the the
staff I have is still the staff a lot of
the staff that I had at CNN and the
staff that I had at Fox and a lot of
staff they don't agree with me
politically you know I have atheists I
have Democrats
I have progressives you know I have my
director is from San Francisco and she's
as about as progressive as you can get
we agree on principles and so what are
the principles you guys agree on that we
need to try to be good to one another we
need to take care of one another we can
be better tomorrow
don't fuel hate but as we as we have
gone through this there with me because
I've looked to them and said how am I
missing it what am i help me help me how
can I you know and so I've had many of
my advisers are the ones who don't agree
with me
some of my best friends are people who
don't agree with me politically and
they've helped me a lot
um but I don't know how to mix I don't
think you can I don't know how you mix
politics with reality because I don't
think politics is real so this is this
is actually a good segue so I'd love to
ask you I know where we're running tight
on time now but just before we close up
a couple of questions from from people
on Facebook and I think that at least
one or two of them will perhaps offer an
opportunity to as you did earlier
correct some misperceptions and so on so
the first one is is from Matt brand and
the question is and again I have no no
agenda and asking this I'm very curious
dare you answer it if you were do
theoretically be reborn as a disabled
gay woman into a poor family what
political system would you want in place
a libertarian one the one that I'm
advocating for I'd love to hear you
elaborate one where we are free to be
who we are we are judged on the content
of our character not our abilities color
of our skin or sexual preferences or our
political preferences I mean the most
power to the individual is the system
that I want and it's the one that I
think the Constitution gives us not the
Constitution that we've been living
under for a hundred years
we don't we don't even recognize the
Constitution anymore but one where the
individual is empowered at the maximum
and the government is at the minimum
although we do need government so
suppose it's it's almost like a it's one
of the most famous track coaches and I'm
blanking on his name said he's he's
broken dozens of World Records isn't for
our body but he said the goal is to do
the least amount necessary not the most
possible yes
yes that's way government should be the
next question is from Alex Kirby and it
is what are some of the things we can do
to quote rebrand capital
and encourage entrepreneurship to people
here in the US and abroad tell stories
tell the stories like what you do you
know let people see what's really
happening in America know the the
media's full of crap and and nobody in
the media is empowered to tell the story
of the people who are reinventing the
world because they're reinventing the
world that doesn't include the people
who have all the power right now you
know I mean so the best thing we can do
is as individuals look for the stories
of the people who are changing the world
I really feel that a gift that that I
have that I want to use is to be able to
connect and highlight the dreamers and
the doers of tomorrow it's kind of like
what Walt is needed with the with the
space shot to be able to highlight them
and show the American people again you
know it's it's good to dream and and we
will make it but highlight those those
people and and look for those people and
stop stop considering what we're doing
now capitalism because we're not doing
capitalism we're in some sort of crony I
don't know capitalism that's just it's
ugly now this isn't capitalism what if
you were to leave people listening to
this with one piece of advice or a
question they can ask themselves what
would that be what role have you played
in the in the dialogue of of humanity
lately are you playing a positive role
or a negative role how can you
change or enhance that to make the most
positive impact who is it that you
should reach out to and go hey dude I
really screwed up I'm really sorry
or I misread you or you misread me and I
want to fix this who have you who or
what have you done that has put you way
out of your comfort zone lately that's a
strong question that's a very very
powerful question one personal question
and then we'll close up with how people
can can find you and what they where
they can learn more about you if you
were in my position I've always tended
to stray away from politics because I
quite frankly don't know what label to
apply to myself I go to fly to Alaska to
go hunting and eat everything I had live
in San Francisco lots of gay friends
like minimal government libertarian I
guess that's what somebody said socially
liberal financially conservative I don't
even know where to start live liberal
and conservatives can get along entirely
if they're libertarian because I'm not
gonna control your life and you're not
gonna control mine so I don't care what
lifestyle you lead it doesn't matter to
me you know let's just be good to each
other you do your thing I'll do my thing
and let's let's just be good to each
other that that's that's how we get
together it's this I'm gonna control
your life and I'm gonna tell you who you
can marry and what you can eat and how
you carry your gun and what you do and
how you do your job and that's crazy
that's crazy each to their own where can
people learn more about you where would
you like people to visit you online
Glenn Beck comm uh you know Facebook
Glenn Beck and the blaze calm wonderful
Glenn thank you so much for taking the
time the pleasure really had a great
time thank you thank you
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by the Tim Ferriss book
club I have a book club where I
resurrect or purchase books that I feel
didn't get the attention they deserved
and there's a brand new book that I have
put out called we learn nothing by tim
Crider and there are I think five others
including several of my favorite books
of all time so to get free samples of
all of them to check them out go to
audible.com forward slash Tim's books
that's audible.com forward slash Tim's
books thank you for supporting the
sponsors this show 99designs which is
your one-stop shop for all things
graphic design related go to 99designs
comm a forward slash Tim to see the
projects that I've put up including the
mock-ups and drafts of the book cover
for the 4-hour body as always you can
subscribe to this podcast on iTunes and
you can find all of the links and
resources from this episode as well as
every other episode by going through
4-hour workweek com forward slash
podcast spell it all out or you can go
to 4-hour work week calm and just click
on podcast feedback if you have feedback
I would love your thoughts anything at
all who you'd like to see on this show
ping me on twitter at Steffes
that's twitter.com /t fer Riss or on
facebook at facebook.com forward slash
Tim Ferriss with two R's and two S's and
until next time thank you for listening